speaking in the very room where the
hearings to impeach him began Donald
Trump this week declared the state of
the American unions stronger than ever a
speech traditionally used by American
presidents to appeal for bipartisan
unity on ambitious political aims became
nothing short of an election rallying
cry as the president took credit for
what he called the great American
comeback many of his listeners will have
found themselves pondering the Democrats
chances of making a comeback after this
week's chaotic primary election in Iowa
our topic today u.s. election year is
trump unstoppable
[Music]
welcome to to the point and it's a
pleasure to introduce our guests
Rick Nowak from the washington post's
berlin bureau he says Trump State of the
Union address was filled with a sense of
vindication both on domestic and foreign
issues but it might be too early for
that with us is also Ralph's front he is
Speaker of Republicans overseas Germany
and his opinion Donald Trump is a
president who delivers on his promises
and it's a pleasure to welcome Rachel
Towson client she's editorial director
at the German Marshall Fund of the
United States
she says Trump is on a very good start
in 2020 but his successes are more show
than substance so in his State of the
Union President Trump was speaking
really just hours before he was
acquitted in the second stage of the
impeachment proceedings which of course
had been expected especially by him was
the enormous confidence that he
projected in his State of the Union
speech a sign that we are now going to
be seeing Trump unleashed and emboldened
well to some extent that's what he
wanted to project but I think when when
you especially looked at the second half
of the speech where he very much
attacked that the Democrats even though
he didn't bring up impeachment itself
you could tell that this is probably
going to become a very ugly election
campaign and impeachment specifically is
going to haunt him Rachel would you
agree Trump unbound yeah well Trump's
always been pretty bold if this was part
of his signature but sure the
Republicans have now basically told him
go for it we're all behind you do what
you want and he's gonna take that
forward in the election year I think
well well I think he's a strong
president has the strong support of his
party and which is like and absolutely
necessary for the next nine month let's
take a listen to some of the claims that
he did make in that State of the Union
speech
I am thrilled to report to you tonight
that our economy is the best it has ever
been our military is completely rebuilt
with its power being unmatched anywhere
in the world and it's not even close our
borders are secure our families are
flourishing our values are renewed our
pride is restored and for all of these
reasons I say to the people of our great
country and to the members of Congress
the state of our union is stronger than
ever before so you said it might be too
early for this sense of vindication that
he displayed when you listen to that
list of claims made just there where
would you say time will in fact wind up
proving the president wrong well there
could be a number of issues that could
be coming up during this year one of
them is certainly or his comments on the
so-called Islamic state we don't know to
what extent that group could could
regroup in in Syria Iraq over the next
month UN certainly is saying that's a
risk when you look at trade there are a
number of unknowns especially when it
comes to the trade deal with China and
potentially even the impact of the
coronavirus on that whether China will
be it's so hard that it can't fulfill
what it what it's signed in this first
agreement and so so there are a number
of issues North Korea as well or sort of
the fears in Europe that he might still
trigger a trade war or some dispute with
the Europeans as well and so so those
are the foreign policy issues bidders of
course a lot of domestic issues as well
and in fact foreign policy didn't figure
strongly in the speech it was very much
about the domestic situation Rachel you
say president Trump's successes are more
show than substance but isn't it true
that the economy is flourishing and that
unemployment is as low as it's been in
decades
unemployment is pretty low it's not as
low as it's ever
as he claimed nor as the economy is
better than it's ever been
so it's true unemployment is is low but
growth is not a very impressive it's
under 3% that's not great and growth
particularly in the manufacturing sector
which is important in places like
Michigan where I'm from that's really
slow it's in it's in fact it undergoing
what they call a technical recession so
the the success is pretty superficial if
all you care about is a stock market
then yes the economy looks great but if
you care about sort of middle-income
actual house called a household income
it's it's a pretty superficial success
that it's tenuous well let's drill down
on a couple of those economic factors
President Trump actually promised four
percent growth when he came into office
as you'll remember as Rachel just
reminded us it's now just above two
percent and he also absolutely claimed
credit for this great American comeback
essentially saying things had been very
dire before he came into office the fact
is the growth trend started under
President Obama and the growth rate was
actually higher under Obama wasn't it
well first of all those bastards effect
know it because we had a lower level
because that was easier like like you
increase the numbers but me as Makana
miss I have to tell you if I compare it
back four years ago they claim when
Trump gets elected the stock market is
gonna tumble the economy is gonna crash
create the trade war is going to happen
nothing happened we have more trade we
have a higher GDP a gross domestic
product we have have you have lower
unemployment rates it's fabulous now I
have to argue well he still growth but
now there's a quality of growth so I
think we were talking about two
different issues and also on trade for
example the aluminum and steel tariffs
the Ford company in Michigan it hurts
more our trade partners who do unfair
trade he announced that before he got
elected one of the few presidents who
told listen it's gonna hurt you in the
long run you're gonna benefit he told
that the his his voters the truth let me
ask you Rick to come in also on a trade
policy because the president said in the
state
the Union quite explicitly that his
trade policy his trade war with China
was responsible for job growth would you
say that is true well in fact it has
caused a lot of damage and nightmares to
a lot of people it's currently not clear
if it's going to lead to the sort of
growth
he has predicted I think so far that
trade war has mainly been damaging it
could be an advantage that now he has
reached some sort of first agreement but
but certainly it hasn't contributed to
to growth to have a trade war happen if
we look at sectors like Steel Rachel
mentioned it steel prices went up quite
dramatically after those tariffs there
were some new jobs created in sector but
economists are analyzing that the cost
of each of those jobs with $900,000
because of the macroeconomic costs that
our trade Paris yeah so how do you
reconcile that how does that match mean
well you got investment how do you what
tell me that as a benefit well you got
invest before you earn I mean they're
very simplistic
the damage to the overall economy
because of unfair trade with China with
with Southeast Asia in general it's much
larger than the small sector of a steel
and aluminium
you've got to invest you gotta hurt
before you earn the money I think as you
mentioned I think in the mid and long
run we're gonna follow that up very
carefully I think we gonna everybody's
going to benefit them there dramatically
but if you want to improve yes or you
know change change the trade
relationship with China and this is the
big problem and I would I would disagree
I would agree with you there isn't it
kind of unclever to start a war with
your allies who could be on the side of
helping you change relations well me as
I read who's even involved in such trade
talks on the very low level at the mmm
Germany I got to tell you the Germans
tend to you know go to Washington
whether it's George Bush jr. or Obama or
Clinton and they all complain about this
this trade barrier the tariffs and
nothing has happened at some point you
have to start and I think he did
correctly he's got to do to Europe and
he has
also do the same thing to China I think
it's just fair
I think what's certainly accurate to say
is that the Europeans have now seen that
he isn't joking when he I think that's
certainly a real outcome of indeed
they're quite concerned that he may be
setting his sights on them
next up but let me take us to another
sector which is of enormous consequence
for the upcoming election and that's
health care Rachel in that sound bite
that we heard the president talked about
families flourishing would you say that
that's true of middle-class families in
regard to health care and especially
insurance no of course not I mean the
the even Obama's health care reform
which was a huge step and did give
access to many more people than before I
mean it's still a million more yeah 20
million more but you know if the plans
were still pretty expensive and health
care costs are just absorbed lehigh in
the in the United States and you know I
live in Germany and I have social
healthcare the coverage isn't better
right and people people are realizing
this prescription drug prices are
absurdly high even if they've fallen by
two percent you know fall by two percent
when they're 200 percent too high is is
not enough so the in the section of the
speech where the president talked about
his desire to bring prices for
pharmaceuticals down a number of
Congress people from the Democratic
Party stood up and started calling HR 3
HR 3 that's the name of the bill that
they had proposed to bring
pharmaceutical prices down that was
nixed by Republicans absolutely true and
on the health issue I'm not in line with
it with a but the president have to be
honest I think there could be better
solutions and then the current I'm
the health plan from from the president
I have to admit that but still he talked
to the industry the pharmaceutical
industry and he urged them to lower
prices so he did achieve something it
was it was not that he stood aside let
me ask about come back to the question
of foreign policy as I said it didn't
get a lot of attention in this speech
but we did hear one claim in the clip
that we played from the speech and that
was that American prestige has been
restored is that your perspective Rick
as an American who is based here in
Germany and Europe certainly not in
Europe I mean when you look at the Pew
poll numbers they've show very clearly
that research thanks they show very
clearly that most Europeans do not agree
with that
in in some countries a very small amount
he does have quite high approval ratings
but that's not at all the case in Europe
and and I mean there are numerous
reasons trade being one of them
his very inconsistent foreign policy
that that has repeatedly shown on North
Korea his approach to the Kurds and the
Middle East and in general let me ask
you this and I'll ask Rachel to comment
after that Donna Trump made a very clear
promise in his inaugural address and
during his election campaign in 2016 to
take the u.s. out of what he called the
endless wars especially in the Middle
East you say in your opening statement
that he keeps his promises but that's
one he definitely has not kept well I'm
sure he has less soldiers overseas
that's for sure and he secured it and he
and he secured defense that defence
budget he increased the defense budget
did a pretty good job he did not send
out four hundred thousand phones in his
last year like like Obama did he send
who in three years less than Obama in
one year did actually increase the
forces deployed in the Middle East
that's right but not overall overall
less soldiers overseas which is quite an
achievement I believe Trump is not
somebody who started a war he he could
even blame that he stepped back from the
Kurds so you cannot claim him as
somebody who's aggressive Rachel yeah I
mean it's true he didn't start any words
but he's he's aggressive in small
symbolic ways without having a strategy
behind it right this was and you know he
got lucky with general Soleimani that
you know other people would were scared
that this the strike on the Iranian
general but he's you know he's not
pulling out of Wars he doesn't have a
strategy to do it his strategy is shoot
a couple of rockets to have a symbolic
effect and I don't see anything beyond
that do you think it matters to voters I
think it matters less to voters and a
lot of other things frankly and the
problem is voters also they don't follow
these issues that closely and so when he
says he's doing this or that they're
probably gonna believe him so the only
thing it would have to be a pretty
dramatic shift you know a lot more
soldiers or for example much higher
casualty rates for a war with Iran or a
war with Iran which you know not even
gonna go there because we don't have
that kind of time but what I do want to
talk about briefly before we start
taking a look at some of the Democrats
and whether they can actually put up a
good fight Rick is the claim that the
union is stronger than ever again
something we heard there in that clip
doesn't the polarization that was on
display on Tuesday night in the Capitol
very much put the lie to that claim
that's true that that speech and the
reaction by Nancy Pelosi was just
essentially sort of it showed just how
much the country is divided and him
celebrating his his poll ratings I mean
given the state of the economy and so on
they probably should be even higher and
the question is why are they not and if
you ask African Americans Asian
Americans whom he tried to reach out in
this address to whom he tried to reach
out they'll tell you it's it's very much
the other side of the coin
the immigration policies considered by
his critics inhumane and and and other
things did that just aren't aren't
acceptable today well that was very much
a speech to his base we actually heard
the Republicans in the room get up and
start shouting four more years four more
years
we saw him refused to take the house of
the speaker the hand of the speaker well
he didn't shake the head of fries
president pence also also well she
reached her hand out he didn't take it
at the end then she tore up her copy of
the speech those are shocking gestures
for me I have to say this is the highest
level of polarization I have seen in my
lifetime can the president win by
energizing his base alone well he did
four years ago but I think it'll go
further we had this before that the
polls were quite low and the outcome was
quite high now even the polls are pretty
I'm pretty confident with the polls
currently and I think the outcome is
gonna be even higher because now he has
a track record he can prove what he
achieved and he delivered a lot of
things as we know you might not like it
and who might not appreciate it but he
deliver it I think he's a very
convincing president so polarization
presents the Democrats with a major
dilemma to defeat Trump they need a
candidate who can mobilize their most
passionate voters on the left or should
they choose someone with broader appeal
possibly even to moderate voters with no
party affiliation
this week's chaotic primary election in
Iowa shows just how difficult that
choice will be the Iowa caucuses rising
star Pete Budaj
the only openly gay candidate the 38
year old mayor from South Bend Indiana
is considered a centrist job iDEN former
vice president under Barack Obama is
also a centrist candidate the 77 year
old sets his hope on balancing the camps
we choose unity over division and guess
what we choose truth over lies
it's the oldest candidate Bernie Sanders
who's popular among young voters the 78
year old senator from Vermont calls
himself a Democratic Socialist
[Music]
Sanders wants to raise taxes on the
wealthiest Americans scrap tuition fees
and implement universal health insurance
coverage with one of these candidates be
able to win an election against Trump so
let me put that question straight away
to all of you who could beat Trump if
anybody well that's a difficult question
but Joe Biden certainly looks a lot
weaker than he did when when all of this
began Bernie Sanders is very forceful in
some would say he at least has sort of
the temperament that could help beat a
Trump but I think a lot of people in the
middle of what would seriously doubt
that and and then there is Elizabeth
Warren and Peter Budaj who also seemed a
little currently below the curve for
people who might make it Elizabeth
Warren didn't figure in that report
Rachel because she didn't come out so
well in Iowa although she yeah she
didn't come out so badly either so let's
bring her into the mix and who do you
think could be if anybody I think they
could all be Trump frankly it's I mean
you have to remember who who lost it
from last time was Hillary Clinton and
Hillary Clinton was not a candidate who
would either excite the sort of young
far left part of the Democratic parties
nor was she a candidate I could win over
you know sort of moderate Republicans or
independents because she had been kind
of the hated to figure why did you get
nominated them well so why did she
succeed
I mean who seemed like a safe choice at
the time but you know it was her or her
deficits were pretty clear okay but you
have a favorite among the the four that
I mean look I think coming out of Iowa
we have two strong centrist candidates
and neither one of them is Biden and two
strong left so Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren representing the left I think I
personally think Warren has better
chance of getting independent voters
than Sanders while also exciting his
left wing so I feel like she's the
stronger one on the left
well if you asked me if I have fear for
anybody no I don't but I think I'm a
mixture of Biden and put it judge I like
that the moderate ones they can you know
they can cover both dreams I think
they're they have the best chances and
don't forget mr. Bloomberg yeah right
the billionaire in the wings Bernie
Sanders looking at him I sometimes feel
like he's the left wing version of Trump
is that a plus if that's if you think
that's true
maybe don't would you say that's a plus
or a minus for him well I think looking
at it from Europe he doesn't look like
the Trump of America because a lot of
his positions are frankly quite quite
similar to mainstream believe here so
but putting that aside it could help him
because a Trump is such a like a
candidate who would defies the norms of
politics the way we've seen it over the
last decades in the United States so
perhaps I think his supporters hope at
least
Sanders can beat him by by being
different wouldn't he be demolished by
Trump for his claim to be a socialist
Rachel if you look at polls 70% of
Americans say they're not so sure about
socialism yeah 70% of undecided voters
sorry John Kerry was overheard in Iowa
in a hotel room saying that he might
enter the race in order to stop Sanders
clearly at least the party establishment
is very worried about Sanders yeah I
think the party establishment is very
worried I'm not sure that they're right
to be so worried frankly the party
establishment were the ones who thought
he really couldn't was a much safer
choice but in fact it is that one word
socialist that is going to be a big
weakness for Sanders and because
Americans here socialist they think
communists we just don't have the same
three of social democracy and that's
gonna take too much explaining for
Sanders it's it's gonna be tough to
support a little of Sanders I have to
admit even Trump didn't have to support
at the party and he bypassed the party
and did pretty well
so even Sanders could bypass the party
and do pretty well so this is not
something I would worry about be worried
about that actually brings me to the
question of whether any of these
candidates can unify the fractious
Democratic Party the way that Trump has
brought his party into lockstep right
but that only really happened after the
election right so yeah as you've said it
might not even be necessary to to to run
this campaign
ritual it's often said that Pete Buddha
church doesn't have what it takes to
attract minority voters and that it will
be absolutely crucial for successful
Democratic candidate to mobilize them do
you think that's true and could it
change so the you know the polls so far
would indicate that that is his big
weakness but it could change right a lot
of a lot of minority voters is from the
african-american voters they want to go
with what's sure so Pete but a judge
looks like he's a winner then I think in
the end they'll they'll support him but
you know South Carolina is gonna be an
important primary yes because Ohio is a
pretty is a pretty what white state as
well be whites aids so like than the
check if he can like attract minorities
it's not improving yet what difference
if any and I'll ask you to be very brief
if you would do you think the
impeachment process will make to those
undecided voters the undecided that's no
story they want the outlook they look at
the economy look at the finances they
look definitely at health insurance
that's gonna be one of the big topics I
don't think impeachments gonna be a
topic in three to six months Rick what
could happen between now and November to
change the equation and I'm taking us
back to our title and stop this
president who right now looks
unstoppable he himself probably because
he's been so unpredictable and and
that's why a lot of countries a lot of
some dick to some dictators for him
another
stoned it's it's really himself he can
he can change the equation Rachel yeah I
think either some kind of you know chaos
and scandal which you know we've already
seen a few of these comes stuck so far
yeah or or economy I think you know so
if something changes there that's also
gonna be a problem for him
Ralph is he gonna be elected again very
hurt too far away to call I can't say it
he has good chance it's better than last
time but if he wins for sure I can't
call her right now okay thanks very much
to all of you for being with us and
thanks to all of you out there for
tuning in see you soon
[Music]
[Music]